[Música]
i
quería empezar por cuando dios creó las
cosas añadió una segunda a cada una de
ellas
voy a ser ya dejó la razón
voy contigo dejo la rebelión voy al
desierto dijo la miseria hoy contigo
dijo la salud
la abundancia dijo voy a egipto
en realidad he venido aquí
para hablar después de 1600 años que
este hombre que es un
qué es un israelita especializan
israelitas y convertido en el islam pero
bueno en realidad después de 1600 en el
vino un hijo y nieto del faraón que
estaba presente con ustedes hablando de
egipto la maravilla de egipto las
culturas egipcias que ha estado en todo
el mundo en realidad
hoy no voy a tener mucho tiempo sobre
ello pero hoy es un día muy especial
para mí porque es mi cumpleaños
justamente el 14 de septiembre que es el
día del cristo pero a pesar de eso todo
el mundo me está preguntando cuántos
años tengo pues ahora si la voy a decir
pues yo tengo 5600 años
qué poco no bueno hablando de egipto
y hablando de la experiencia y este país
que me ha dado también no voy a olvidar
un país muy importante para mí que es
españa españa
me ha llenado y me ha enriquecido me ha
dado muchas cosas me ha dado a estudiar
a vivir a estar en muchos sitios a
través de españa y a través de los
españoles y yo he integrado yo me siento
muy español
pero también no voy a encantar tantas
cosas sobre españa también hay una
ventaja y desventajas
hoy he venido para hablar de algo muy
importante sobre mi experiencia que he
pasado que es como tú mismo
eliges entre sentir lástima o que podría
superarlo voy a hablar un poco de algo
muy importante yo he venido aquí a hacer
mi carrera me ha integrado tanto con la
sociedad me ha amado mucho españa he
entrado dentro de mi sangre y he tenido
una relación familiar muy bonita
muy interesante pero bueno el tiempo se
me ha fracasado pero no eso no significa
que el fracaso significa que yo me
pierdo más controles en mis nervios al
revés de todo eso
gracias a esta relación la tengo todo el
cariño pero no hemos funcionado
he empezado a sentirme que debo hacer
ahora con todo lo que he hecho con todo
lo que ha aprendido debo caer debe
empezar a caer en formarme o lo que sea
o hacerme o caer todo mi carrera al
revés yo he puesto solo yo leyendo me
poniendo muy fuerte y decir a partir de
ahora yo tengo que sentirme que valgo
algo por muchas cosas no solamente valgo
por la ciencia que ha aprendido no yo
puedo hacer muchas cosas entonces empecé
a el camino poco a poco
y darme confianza en mí mismo porque yo
valgo porque yo soy algo
a partir de ahí empecé a aprender si yo
hubiese venido aquí para aprender el
doctorado y hacerla pues yo me empeñado
con todas las fuerzas y con todo el
sentimiento que me ha dado para hacer
lástima de mí no yo valgo mucho entonces
empecé a meterme en más cosas y valerme
por mí mismo para llegar a hacer muchas
cosas no vengo a hablar la de ella pero
supuestamente he aprendido con los
idiomas que yo domino y manejo como
relacionarme con la gente cómo puedo
ganar a la gente cómo puedo romper el
hielo cómo puedo ganar en negocios a
tratar con la gente es algo muy
importante entonces el fracaso se puede
ser y superar y llegar a superar lo
máximo es algo muy importante que me
llamó la atención
también en que yo podría estar en muchos
países y yo viajo represento muchos
organismos ahora mismo soy de la liga
árabe que es algo no es como la unión
europea trabajo en ella con todo mi
esfuerzo soy periodista estoy con todos
los organismos del estado español porque
porque yo mismo lo creo para algo yo
podría haber caído de la lástima como
mucha gente puede pasar no solamente
aquí en españa en españa en todas partes
del mundo se les pasa entonces de eso
punto he querido aprender de mis fallos
para valer por mí mismo es decir yo soy
capaz de hacer todo lo que he podido
hacerlo y voy a hacer más
entonces yo invito a todo el mundo que
todos tenemos momentos de fracasos nadie
es perfecto excepto el dios pero
nosotros somos humanos entonces tenemos
que aprender bien de nuestro fracaso
cómo superamos esto cómo valemos por
nuestro mismo cómo podemos caminar no me
caído en muchas cosas pero al revés me
levantado después un faraón me he puesto
que valgo por mí mismo que yo soy capaz
de hacer todo eso entonces simplemente
he venido para comentar esto muchísimas
gracias y yo grande dylan
[Aplausos]